I think Bitcoin could have bottomed at
around 17 and a half if FTX didn't
happen but there's so much dodgy
dealings happening behind the scenes
that if more stuff comes to light then I
see no reason why it won't go lower
weird stuff is happening with crypto.com
the CEO came out and said they
accidentally sent billions of dollars of
customer funds to gate.io which is
another exchange what do you mean you
accidentally sent billions of dollars of
customer funds you know and then you see
gate.io sending the money back you can
look at it on the blockchain it's so
dodgy so if if another exchange like
up then yeah I think we're going
much lower but I don't really care
getting in at this price is such a steal
like this time I'll share Bitcoins at 69
000 people would like gray and wish for
these prices